l'image de chaouch et morel a été montré
à la télévision romane c'est la preuve
de la fin des petits vont détester
yoni les sources est le nouveau leader
romain c'est l'homme fort du nouveau
pouvoir qui déjà a pris toute une série
de décisions
la mère d'un des grands écrivains de ce
siècle samuel beckett il avait 95 ans il
avait reçu le prix nobel en souhaitant
tout bon soir la preuve à être la porte
roman sur la télévision roumaine libre
qui une fois encore a mis un point final
à l'incertitude et au chaos de cette
semaine romaine ce matin en fin de
matinée la télévision a diffusé une
courte séquence dans laquelle on peut
reconnaître le corps sans vie de nicolae
ceausescu le tyran a définitivement
cessé de nuire
il en est de l'histoire c'est en vertu
d'une loi qu'il avait lui-même sa mule
guéant 68 que le dictateur ait pu
exécuter cette loi prévoit en effet que
les crimes particulièrement graves en
rapport avec la défense et la sécurité
de l'état par exemple sont jugés par un
tribunal militaire dont la sentence est
sans appel
hervé brusini au loin un murs criblés de
balles
à terre le couple ceausescu la caméra
s'avance comme pour mieux prouver la
vérité de l'événement oui ceausescu est
bien mort mepha est savait-il en sortant
de se blinder que le peloton d'exécution
était déjà prêt pour l'heure la
télévision roumaine n'a encore donné
aucun détail sur les circonstances de la
mort des chevauchées ce coup seuls
éléments donnés par ces images c'est
bien l'armée qui détenait le couple un
tribunal militaire extraordinaire a été
constituée et commentateurs extreme
pendant ce temps ceausescu dans ce
regard à la caméra autre coup d'oeil
mon médecin cette fois dérision d'un
examen médical pour futurs condamnés à
mort le speaker égrène les chefs
d'accusation de génocide noyautage de
l'état vol de biens publics à l'hôtel
intercontinental de bucarest une foule
s'est amassée pour voir la somme on
applaudit on crache sur le poste de
télévision
kadi chaouchi secours pendant ces
quelques heures
vous ne le seront pas ces images sont
muettes dernier geste du dictateur
marque de dédain ou impatience d'en
finir
le procès lui-même n'a toujours pas été
diffusées c'est pour raison de sécurité
dit-on que son passage à l'antenne a été
différée et tout un peuple se sent
frustré de n'avoir pas assisté au
jugement de son tyran beaucoup de peps
les 1 500 selon les les abominables
or elle promis j'ai prié en scope pas
dérobé ce qui est c'est à dire en
français peur nous avons eu
la bête et moi rabais témoin et ils ont
parlé toute la journée de 7 morts
comme à la recherche de ce moment qui
leur avait échappé à timisoara la ville
martyre celle qui la première s'est
soulevé contre le régime
le calme est aussi revenu comme à
bucarest aujourd'hui timsoara qu'on fait
meurt il semble que les bilans même
s'ils sont tragiques soit moins
effrayant que ce qu'on avait craint
stéphane magnier claude sicard nos
envoyés spéciaux en transylvanie ont
recueilli à timisoara
d'autres réactions après la mort du
congo 14 le goûter hier soir le hall de
l'hôtel astoria à arad
ils sont une vingtaine qui ne rentreront
pas chez eux de la nuit ils regardent la
télé ils attendent ils veulent voir pour
être sûr que c'est vrai pour tourner une
grande page de leur vie pour vivre la
mort d'un dictateur
diano ty s des chalets qui les 1000 et
2000 à benghazi destin ils sont pourtant
satisfaits que frustré ceausescu a
emporté ses secrets avec lui dans la
tombe qui était compromis avec l'ancien
pouvoir
et jusqu'où à radio timisoara les
soldats protègent la station la relève
exténué dort à même le sol dans un
studio on a ajouté le mauvais livre au
nom de la radio puis les journalistes
sont restés les mêmes
si c'est l'arrêt concession c'est la
très difficile
premièrement parce que le peuple romain
le fortis à l'aise
les innocents des champions faudra
attendre une voile va b je me rappelle
de la démocratie de la liberté de la
manque de la terrasse de la tour de ton
voisin de ton ami toujours été des deux
petites filles ce groupe dans lequel tu
pourras avoir de la créance
oui l'exécution rapide de ceausescu a
peut-être fait taire les armes à
timisoara
mais elle a fait naître un autre spectre
celui de la chasse aux sorcières ce
matin les nouveaux dirigeants lyonnais
il y ait ce coup le numéro un est aussi
le nouveau premier ministre et rayman
tous deux se sont expliqués en
exclusivité à nos envoyés spéciaux sur
les objectifs mais aussi sur cette
exécution rapide de l'ancien dictateur
et de sa femme et interviews exclusives
est-ce que vous ne croyez pas qu'en
supprimant les dictateurs supprimant le
succès une pièce coup vous vous privez
de la tête du principal témoin du
principal responsable de tout ce qui
vous est arrivé de tout ce qui peut
dresser plus 25 ans et que jamais vous
ne pourrez établir les réelles
responsabilités aujourd'hui c'est pas
aussi des personnes qui sont élevés
d'une processus très spontanée
démange nalout qui nous après c'est de
faire cette passe également sur la
pression des groupes terroristes qui
voudraient les libanais nous avons
assumé notre responsabilité commune du
conseil mais nous avons utilisé avec
tous les détails la légalité existantes
client d'ita des chevauchées tout c'est
à dire nous avons instruit un processus
dans lequel lui même il devait se
soumettre parce qu'un c'était un
tribunal militaire organisée d'après
certains de présumés donc certaines
normes qui ont été respectées il inclut
des assesseurs populaire du temps durs
du régime de ceausescu d'eau qu'est ce
que c'est le dernier acte de la
dictature est ce que c'est la première
faute de la démocratie c'est pas une
faute de la démocratie on peut être si
c'est peut-être c'est une chouette mais
on ne pouvait pas le dire mais moi je
répète nous étions dans des
circonstances qui nous permettait le
pensons nous pensons aujourd'hui encore
plus qu'il est ce qui nous permettait de
attendre encore
une situation d'instabilité il y avait
précisé ce plus que ça il y avait des
pressions nous avons nous avons besoin
d'informations concernant d'éventuelles
attaques sur wii se trouvait italie
exclusive réalisée par notre cahier
spécial avec l'art est patricia cost
direction bucarest jusqu'à maintenant
vous savez que tous les soirs depuis le
week end
nous sommes en direct avec nos envoyés
spéciaux dans la capitale roumaine pour
tous les journaux grâce à noyers
technique à ce tdf alors tout de suite
me joignant françoise joly l'une de nos
journalistes me soeur françoise bien sûr
toute la jauge imagine pas lukas on a
beaucoup parlé de l'exécution de
chercher secours
effectivement hervé où toute la matinée
j'ai parcouru les rues de bucarest
j'ai rencontré beaucoup de jeunes de
femmes avec qui j'ai parlé de cette
exécution
alors il y avait bien sûr cette première
réaction la joie le bonheur de voir
disparaître celui qu'ils attali si la
bête quand j'ai appris sur nos
discussions a dit m
j'ai crié labat morte et puis il y avait
ce matin ceux qui doutaient encore il
n'avait pas vu les images à la
télévision à la télévision de nicolas et
ceausescu mer et il attendait ces images
comme pour les grades dans leur mémoire
et puis il y avait aussi tout ce qu'ils
auraient aimé que chaouchi ce coup soit
jugé qu' un véritable procès que la
réplique la dictature époque
enfin de tous ces crimes peut-être aussi
pour que toutes les responsabilités
soient établies sur ses 24 ans de
dictature et puis vous savez ce matin à
premier aussi la formation du premier
gouvernement de l'après chaouch est ce
qu'on est bien cette formation est déjà
contesté qu'on a pu le remarquer bruno
gex jean françois kahn et hervé de ce
paris place de la république où se
dérouler cet après midi une importante
manifestation d'étudiants qui parle à la
télévision sont des traîtres ils ont
annoncé qu'il y avait un meeting ici
qu'il ne fallait pas venir
nous voulons la mort du communisme
ça suffit comme ça
place de la république devant le siège
du parti communiste roumain aux balcons
des orateurs prennent la parole à tour
de rôle ils disent représenter un
nouveau parti d'opposition le parti
démocrate
on ne peut pas le régime communiste on
veut la liberté véritable la peur a
disparu mais non nous avons nous voulons
nous voulons avoir des élections libres
une télévision libre et des
représentants de réponse de fond qui
n'ont pas été des membres de partis ça
c'est très important pour nous c'est à
dire pas les vieux qui sont maintenant à
télévision à nouveau comme ouvert nous
voyons les mêmes mots les mêmes visages
les mêmes choses pour nous ce serait
affreux
l'armée ne serait plus solidaires du
peuple roumain la rumeur a couru cet
après-midi dans les rues de bucarest
le gouvernement a déconseillé tout
rassemblement mais beaucoup pis s'ils
veulent encore s'exprimer
il a été arrêté de communisme et il a
été maître dans le pigeon gill avant et
entre 12 prison ici à bucarest et il a
été battu 2
même deux bonnes heures pour thalys nous
voulons aller à des moines y est
parlementaire comme les autres brazen
thomas l'ont fait
nous avons voulu le peuple est avec ma
jeunesse premier rang ont réussi à faire
la révolution
robert c'est tout on ne sait pas
seulement le système désormais le
gouvernement devra compter avec cette
jeunesse qui a fait la révolution et
qu'il ne veut plus de communisme de
rester un direct avec nous à l'ambassade
de france bien sûr vous vous retrouvez
dans quelques minutes mais je voudrais
qu'on revienne à l'instant sur ses
nouveaux dirigeants qui était conspué à
l'instant dans le reportage de bruno gex
l'yonne iliescu petremann va deux noms
que nous serons amenés à prononcer
souvent ce sont eux les hommes forts ce
sont les symboles de la roumanie
nouvelle dès aujourd'hui il a pris toute
une série de décisions
parmi celles ci il n'y a plus
d'obligation en roumanie de s'appeler
camarades
là aussi c'est tout un symbole encore
une perte une abrogation de la loi
instituant la façon de s'adresser entre
citoyens de la république socialiste
roumaine sous entendu le mot de
camarades et abolit les salaires seront
assurés à la fin de chaque mois
la sécurité rattaché à la tutelle
militaire ce sont trois des 25 décret
pris par le nouveau gouvernement en
place à bucarest est annoncé à la
télévision cet après midi au pouvoir du
car est aujourd'hui le front de salut
national
un comité qui s'est constituée dans la
clandestinité jeudi dernier dès la fuite
des époux ceausescu et qui a réellement
pris le pouvoir ce matin après
l'annnonce de l'exécution du dictateur
parmi eux trois groupes de personnalités
des dissidents des militaires mais
surtout beaucoup d'apparatchiks tombé en
disgrâce sous ceausescu
c'est le cas dionne il est ce coup le
nouveau président du conseil
un ancien haut fonctionnaire du parti
pratiquement inconnu en dehors de la
roumanie mais qui dès le premier jour à
la faveur de la confusion a pris de
l'importance
peut-être parce qu'il est le plus
politique de tous anciens membres du
comité central
il est ami de michael gorbatchev avec
lequel il a fait ses études à moscou
à ses côtés le nouveau premier ministre
petre et romane un scientifique de
carrière
la lure jeunes et décontractée qui parle
français il a fait ses études en france
il n'a jusqu'à présent occupé aucune
fonction officielle
il n'était pas non plus un dissident à
l'évidence ce nouveau gouvernement issu
du chaos n'est qu'un gouvernement
transitoire le peuple déjà en conteste
la légitimité
un nouveau parti politique c'est aussi
créer ce matin bucarest le parti
chrétien n'a seulement nationale par
d'un paysan parmi les fondateurs de inna
corner à l'une des plus célèbre
opposante roumaine nous la connaissons
bien en france et particulièrement
antenne 2 en 87 dans notre magazine
résistance elle avait parlé elle avait
dit la vérité une vérité intolérable
pour chercher ce coup maryse mano ce
visage devenu le symbole de la
résistance roumaine nous l'avons
découvert sur antenne 2 en novembre 87
dans sa modeste cuisine de inna cornea
parle pour la première fois face à la
caméra
l'interview va lui coûter très cher
elle utilise toutes les astuces pour
témoigner sur les méthodes chez oc
secoue ses messages écrits serre et
passent la frontière dans des poupées de
chiffon lectrice de français à
l'université de cluj et les taux chômage
pour avoir soumis à ses élèves des
textes interdit et persécuté par la
securitate
on craint pour sa vie et puis on la
retrouve tout à coup sûr notre écran
celui de la télévision roumaine libre
voici ce qu'elle disait ce matin j
mobilisnoo pas d'immobilisme de
l'affinité si vous voulez vraiment nous
aider pas non mais les jeunes il faut
que la jeunesse puisse se reconstruire
ce pays
place aux jeunes
c'est peut-être ce qui explique que de
inna cornea ne fasse pas partie du
nouveau gouvernement
bien qu'elle soit membre du front de
salut national on la retrouve aussi à la
tête du nouveau parti national chrétien
paysan né hier parti qui défend
l'enseignement religieux à l'école
les valeurs traditionnelles de la
roumanie loin de l'idéologie communiste
un symbole en colère dans une actualité
qui n'en est pas d'avoir le siège du
comité central du parti communiste de
bucarest a été débaptisée on s'était
battu autour de l'immeuble du comité
central très violemment pendant cinq
jours et bien les lettres parti
communiste ont été descellées par des
jeunes montés sur le toit une nouvelle
ère commence peu à peu à bucarest
la confiance revient jean-marc ellouze
agnès poirier
pendant une ville en guerre mais mais
sort faire ses courses c'est toujours le
signe que la confiance renaît et ses
quelques alliés place de la république
font presque une victoire de 24 heures
d'accalmie ou de trêve à bucarest libre
toujours sur le pied de guerre toujours
en alerte mais vous le constatez
beaucoup moins nerveux qui hier les
partisans qui apportait ce matin le
métro de bucarest
ici un moment d'exaltation rageuse lors
de l'arrestation d'un suspect peut être
un membre de la securitate et beaucoup
tentent actuellement de se fondre dans
le décor pour fuir vers l'étranger tiens
place du palais présidentiel la foule se
tient debout pour écouter les
proclamations de la radio autre signe
qu'elle ne craint plus ici les tirs
sournois de la police secrète les
nouvelles autorités roumaines semble
avoir réussi à récupérer beaucoup
d'armes mais manifestations d'inquiétude
leurs appels fréquents à se méfier des
provocateurs qui tente de couper l'armée
du peuple alors même que le tout jeune
conseil de front de salut national
bricole avec espoir un gouvernement
provisoire mais déjà souvent reconnus
officiellement à l'ouest comme à l'est
loin des clameurs et des conciliabules
de la politique au coin de la rue on
poussait des autels de fortune
et puis bien sûr l'inévitable cortège de
ceux qui sont tombés hommage de bucarest
à ce qui nous rend tous rêvé qu'un
instant à des lendemains de liberté
les réactions dans le monde tous les
pays peu à peu reconnaissent le nouveau
pouvoir
dernier en date et c'est à ce titre
c'est assez ironique l'iran livrent à un
effet avait été le dernier pays à
recevoir officiellement monsieur charles
huchet secoue la semaine dernière et
pour se justifier
les iraniens ont démis de ses fonctions
leurs ambassadeurs à des caresses motif
ils n'avaient pas assez informé les
autorités iraniennes sur la situation
réelle
en roumanie c'est carrément drôle sur
l'exécution elle-même les réactions sont
en général dans la même tonalité que
celle de la france donnée ici même par
le premier ministre par intérim lionel
jospin hier soir tout le monde aurait
préféré un procès le père parole du
ministère soviétique des affaires
étrangères a dit que l'exécution
ceausescu répondait tellement au voeu du
peuple roumain alors jacques merino ce
nouveau pouvoir
il a donné ses raisons de l'exécution ou
mais elles ne sont pas les amène à
d'autres raisons oui la raison
officielle n'a été donnée tout à l'heure
vous l'avez entendu il y avait
semble-t-il un risque que les aime de la
securitate et puis j'ai livré nicolas tu
sais ce que c'est une affirmation à
évaluer mais il reste qu'il est sans
doute très difficile pour le nouveau
gouvernement d'organiser des procès en
forme
pourquoi et bien parce qu'il y avait
trop de gens complices du pouvoir nous
fait comprendre et c'est très important
que dans ce système
horrible qui vient de prendre un chacun
pour survivre et est obligé de composer
et de donner des gages certains le
faisons un peu d'autres et ont les mains
propres
cela très grande majorité le combien
sont ils à s'être complètement peu
promis 100 milles ça s'anime et millions
on n'en sait rien on sait seulement
qu'ils sont si nombreux que ces procès
serait sans fin et durerait des années
ce sans doute ce qui a conduit ce
nouveau gouvernement à choisir une
méthode expéditive la vie tout à l'heure
dans le reportage de bruno gex à
bucarest il y à déjà à une contestation
ce ne sera pas facile car nouveau
pouvoir
oui en fait on retrouve ici la même
situation qu en allemagne de l'est ou en
tchécoslovaquie à pouvoir contester
aussi tôt qu'au mise en place en fait le
problème de fin pour tous ces pays et
qu'il n'y a pas d' équipe de relève
capable d'assumer totalement le pouvoir
il n'y a pas d' équipe de relève
puisqu'il n'avait pas d'opposition
autorisée et donc des structures
permettant adm de se préparer à
gouverner et nous on trouve le nouveau
pouvoir dans tous ces pays doivent donc
travailler avec d'anciens communistes
cela constitue évidemment de nombreuses
raisons de contestation merci jacques et
tout de suite
retour à bucarest avec françoise olic le
retrouve en direct alors françoise on
n'a pas tout mis à part le tout à
l'heure mais aujourd'hui la situation
était beaucoup plus calme à bucarest
tout à fait tirs sporadiques continuent
autour de points stratégiques comme la
télévision partout ailleurs la vie se
réorganise et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
les gens un peu beaucoup plus nombreux
dans les rues de la capitale surtout
dans les quartiers commerçants et cela
tout simplement parce que le nouveau
pouvoir alimente les magasins ben à
manger aux guillemins c'est ce que vous
avez pu constater cet après midi avec
roger waite mrda failles et ses cartons
que ces hommes des charges avec beaucoup
de soin contiennent de la viande de
boeuf jamais autant de chaouch et ce
coup elle n'aurait été livrés dans ce
goût et d'un quartier de bucarest
la population n'avait droit qu'aux zaba
de volaille au pied de cochon tout le
reste le meilleur parti à l'exportation
pis si nous n'avions drouot petits
morceaux
une espèce îlots mixte doignon de temps
et de presse
je crois que si vous aviez donné sans un
chien à la rue il ne l'aurait pas manger
cette femme roddick à galati dieu a
voulu aussi montré le mépris de chaouchi
scoop pour le peuple rom
voilà notre nourriture
juste le fait de manger
aujourd'hui pour se ravitailler les gens
faisaient la queue devant les magasins
mais roddick à galati diu nous
expliquera ici avant l'insurrection
la tente était bien plus longue et que
très souvent ils attendaient pour bien
avant de rentrer chez elle dans une zone
où les combats continuent cette femme de
bucarest nous a dit son espoir
oui nous sommes libres maintenant mais
je vais gagner nous allons commencer une
vraie vie ce soir devant son immeuble un
char est toujours en position car sur le
toit des tireurs isolés ait encore
haussé tireur françoise est ce que hier
nous disiez que votre immeuble était
encerclé par les tireurs ce soir est ce
que c'est le cas encore encerclé le mot
est peut-être un peu fort vers le sait
dès qu'il y avait des tireurs postés sur
les immeubles sur des immeubles autour
de l'ambassade peut-être où sont ils
encore ce soir une seule beaucoup moins
offensif avant le match j'étais entré
dans la cour de l'ambassade et pour la
première fois depuis que je suis ici
depuis quatre cinq joueurs je n'ai pas
entendu de tirs
il y avait tout ce que je peux vous dire
ce soir ici à bucarest et je vous
retrouve dans la prochaine édition
merci fantasio lee les obsèques de jean
louis calderon notre confrère de l'a5
seront célébrées jeudi prochain 14
heures à paris ce une chapelle ardente
sera installée dès mercredi sur les
cales de rein avait trompé il a laissé
sa vie en faisant son métier de
journaliste
d'autres journalistes étrangers honte
aussi été tués ou blessés
hormis cette semaine le peuple roumain
vient de perdre des milliers d'hommes et
de femmes et le voilà qui pleurent la
mort d'un journaliste
les roumains sont émus nous aussi
vendredi soir jean luc elles devront
était au coeur des combats les tirs la
violence les blindés qui font mouvement
patrice du tertre le cameraman qui perd
de vue son camarade jean-luc elles
devront disparaît très maigre hommage
rendu par l'ambassade de france
la fougue aux anonymes qui part vers une
femme et deux enfants
c'est la mort d'un journaliste reporter
omniprésent sur le terrain leurs
commandes volonté de témoigner
l'anniversaire force de leur dette par
exemple d'amis
ma liste belge a lui aussi trouvé la
mort à bucarest mais le tfc ancien agent
tout cela pour que le monde puisse voir
pour que le monde puisse savoir
aujourd'hui sortent tous les pompiers
qui combattent issil incendies depuis
cinq heures du matin sont formels le
bilan même s'il n'est pas bizouard tient
pour l'instant du miracle et ce d'abord
grâce aux conditions météorologiques il
n'y a pas eu ni ce matin mais dans le
courant de la journée ne portera pas le
devant qui aurait pu propagé l'incendié
demain 22h25 spécial bucarest sur
l'antenne de notre chaîne a décidé de
bouleverser ses programmes et de
présenter demain soir une émission
spéciale du cac reste très interclubs
ses rayons pour retracer les événements
de ces derniers jours et vous montrer
les reportages de nos envoyés spéciaux
en roumanie
le reste de l'actualité maintenant et le
panama bien sur cette affaire qui n'est
pas encore réglée pour l'instant c'est
toujours l'impasse entre washington et
le vatican
la nonciature du panama c'est à dire
l'ambassade du vatican abrite toujours
le général noriega qui s'y réfugier et
le vatican ne veut pas le rendre
impatience à washington jacques adoue
chars les soldats américains
maintiennent une pression constante
autour de la nonciature à panama
george bush a téléphoné au nonce en
pleine nuit et l'on admet du côté
américain que la remise de noriega a été
réclamé au représentant du pape dans des
termes très durs
le ministre de la défense monsieur dick
cheney qui a partagé la dinde de noël
avec les jazz et inspecter des stocks
d'armes récupérées n'a laissé place à
aucun doute sur les intentions de
washington se sont venus pour sauver des
vies américaines et restaurer la
démocratie mais aussi pour capturer
noriega et le traduire en justice
autres tâches prioritaires la
réinstallation de milliers de réfugiés
chassés de chez eux par les combats et
les bombardements des tout premiers
jours lorsque l' us air force a pilonné
le quartier général des forces
panaméenne le ministre chesnais a
d'ailleurs confirmé l'entrée en action
pour la première fois du chasseur
stealth dit invisible car indétectable
par les radars
ces raids ont provoqué la destruction de
plusieurs centaines de maisons en bois
et le nombre des victimes civiles n'est
toujours pas connue l'aspect militaire
de l'intervention panama et désormais
reléguées au second plan
le véritable enjeu c'est le sort qui
sera réservé à nos égards et la
possibilité actuellement exclue à
washington que l'ancien dictateur puisse
obtenir un sauf conduit pour se rendre à
l'aéroport et quitter le pays
voyons maintenant le reste de
l'actualité en quelques séquences brève
avec louis carzou frais tout d'abord
comme un leitmotiv la violence au liban
une fois encore
liban-sud de nouveau dans la tourmente
de raid israélien contre le parti
communiste libanais pro syriens ont fait
sept morts et une vingtaine de blessés
c'est dans cette même région que
s'affrontent depuis samedi le hezbollah
pro iranien et les prosyriens d'amal des
combats qui ont déjà fait 32 victimes et
150 blessés l'armée syrienne dispose
d'importants postes de contrôle dans
cette zone de la plaine orientale de la
bekaa
risques d'épidémies de méningite
cérébrospinale dans le loiret très
limitée après 24 heures de mobilisation
dans les hôpitaux de la région
seul un nouveau cas a été décelé hier
soir chez un lycéen de 17 ans à présent
hors de danger
l'alerté avait été déclenchée après le
décès de deux lycéens de montargis
atteints de septicémie foudroyante très
légère baisse du chômage en novembre la
mp a recensé deux millions cinq cent
vingt-trois mille 700 chômeurs soit 0,1
pour cent de moins qu'en octobre
le taux de chômage dans la population
active reste important à 9 5% depuis le
mois de mars mais sur 12 mois le nombre
de chômeurs en france a baissé d'un peu
plus de 1%
une tendance satisfaisante selon le
ministre du travail
calme plat à la bourse de paris où le
marché très peu actif a terminé la
séance sur une petite baisse de 0 20%
même tendance hivernale pour la devise
américaine le dollar cotait aujourd'hui
5 francs 80 90 en légère baisse
la mort d'un géant de la littérature
samuel beckett et mer vendredi dernier à
paris à l'âge de 93 ans son éditeur ne
l'annoncé que ce matin selon la volonté
de l'écrivain l'auteur d' en attendant
gaubert était à dublin était né pardon à
dublin mais c'est en france qu'il
souhaitait installer avant la guerre il
fuyait les honneurs mais il avait reçu
le nobel
il n'aimait que la solitude mais ces
pièces sont les plus joués dans le monde
entier
actuellement cv marion ma région
quelques photos c'est tout ce qui nous
reste de l'homme samuel beckett le plus
grand mais le plus secret des auteurs
dramatiques de l'après guerre
jamais il n'a voulu se prêter aux
interviews même lorsqu'il a reçu le prix
nobel qu'il n'est pas allé chercher à
stockholm
l'irlandais beckett ami de james joyce
est venu comme lecteur d'anglais à paris
où il fait installer avant la guerre il
a participé activement à la résistance
et s'est mise à écrire en français à
l'âge de 40 ans il a été découvert par
les éditions de minuit où il a publié 22
livre le mystère de la parole fut son
unique préoccupation
son seul sujet ce n'est pas comme chez
descartes je pense donc je suis mais
c'est plutôt j'ai ce n'est pas non plus
jaurès meilleur donc je suis c j'écris
donc je suis au je parle donc je suis en
attendant godot le titre de la plus
célèbre des pièce de beckett joué dans
plus de 30 langues est devenu proverbial
attendre godot faisait partie des
expressions courantes dans les années 50
même si on ne connaissait pas son
théâtre
d'avant-garde le théâtre de beckett est
devenu classique c'est par classe
entière que les lycéens vont voir or les
deux jours que madeleine renaud a créé
et qu'on joue régulièrement depuis plus
de 20 ans
à
pour jours encore pour moi ç'aurait ce
que nous dit beckett c'est qu'au delà de
leur angoisse de la solitude de l'homme
il y à la grandeur de l'homme lui même
dans les plus petites choses de la vie
ça va être le silence là où je suis je
ne sais pas je ne le saurai jamais dans
le silence on ne sait pas il faut
continuer je ne peux pas continuer je
vais rentrer comme chaque jour quelques
informations pratiques d'abord les
résultats tiercé quinté plus c'était à
vincennes d'abord le tiercé 10-15 pardon
17 et 6 je vous laisse lire les rapports
quinté+
15 17 6 et 19 les rappeurs c'est encore
plus compliqué mais vous les voyez sur
notre écran c'est la météo avec sophie
davant la dernière édition ce sera
philippe gassot vers 23h30 premier
journal de la rédaction d'un matin c'est
à cette heure avec claire chazal
bonne soirée sur un thème 2 à demain 20
heures